today on the matt walsh show the leading
lgbt children's author in the world was
suspended from twitter over the weekend
it was an appalling act of homophobia
but there's something even deeper and
more important going on which we'll talk
about today also the cdc has finally
started admitting some basic truths
about the covet virus just in time for
the midterm elections but you know
that's a coincidence i'm sure and the
teacher stuffs her son in the trunk of
her car so that she doesn't give her so
that he doesn't give her covid
interesting parenting strategy plus navy
boot camp goes woke and we must cancel a
prominent doctor who posted a dramatic
25 tweet thread about his son's battle
with a cold all of that and more today
on the matte wall show
[Music]
well as you all know and have seen true
masculinity is constantly under attack
in our culture and we need core pillars
to keep us grounded
in true masculinity one such pillar is
steak and not just any steak though you
need 100
american steak on your dinner table
fortunately for you good ranchers is the
exclusive meat company of the daily wire
they help you get american meat
delivered to your door they've got 100
american steakhouse quality uh meat and
it's it's all for an affordable price
over 85 percent of the grass-fed beef in
stores and online is imported from
overseas and that means you're getting
less quality also means that you're
undermining american farms and ranches
and often that causes them to close down
ultimately shop good ranchers today to
support american-made and put the small
farm back on top support american farms
and ranches and get delicious t-bones
gourmet burgers rib eyes and many more
mouth-watering cuts in the process i
mean the the big headline for me with
this is that this is just really good
stuff i've had i've tried the product
myself
and um it is this is this is one of
those easy
spots to do because i actually really
enjoy it not that i don't enjoy the
other sponsors anyway visit
goodranchers.com walsh and use codewall
should check out to get 30 off any one
of their many boxes everything they sell
is truly top notch and you really have
to try it so visit goodranchers.com
walsh today to save 30 on your new
favorite steak start the year with good
ranchers american meat delivered
so tragedy struck my family on friday
when i got the news which came
completely out of nowhere hitting like a
bolt of lightning from the clear blue
sky
that i had been suspended from twitter
these are truly the times that try men's
souls i was informed of the suspension
mere moments after posting a video of me
defeating my wife in a plastic sled race
in our front yard now at first i thought
that i was being suspended because of
that video perhaps on a bullying charge
or something either way you know that's
the kind of indispensable content that
the internet was deprived of in my
absence then i received the email from
our twitter overlords they informed me
that the suspension was for two
offensive posts that i had recently
authored
one said this
trigger warning get ready for this this
is what it says
the greatest female jeopardy champion of
all time is a man the top female college
swimmer is a man the first female
four-star admiral in the public health
service is a man men have dominated
female high school track and the female
mma circuit the patriarchy wins in the
end the other was a tweet from a few
months ago i think was a few months ago
and i was responding i believe to the
news that demi lovato had come out as a
they them she had come out as multiple
people
where i said in my trademark diplomatic
and gentle style i am not referring to
an individual person as if she is two
people everyone else can run around
sounding like maniacs if they want to
but i will not be participating no thank
you
well i did say no thank you so i think i
was pretty polite about it
what rules did these two posts violate
well the company said that i'd run a
foul of their policy prohibiting hateful
conduct
what is hateful conduct
that's this is the only explanation they
offer for that they say
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
now it should be noted that you can
still promote violence against them if
you just disagree with their opinions
because people do that to me every
single day i mean every day someone is
telling me they're going to kill me or
wishing death on my entire family but
that's okay because they just hate me
for everything i stand for and believe
that's totally fine
hate somebody for their race or gender
on the other hand well that is
unacceptable
but did i promote violence i mean did i
make any threats against anybody
i said the patriarchy wins but that was
simply an observation not a threat
i didn't say the patriarchy will win you
fools you're all gonna pay
that's the kind of thing i might say
but that's not what i mean that's what i
hope it will happen but that's that's
not what i actually said
so where was the threat or was i guilty
of harassment
was i harassing the trans jeopardy
contestant by simply observing in a
tweet where he was not tagged or even
mentioned by name that he's a biological
male
now if i had to guess and all i can do
is guess because social media companies
never deign to explain themselves to
plebes like us but if i had to guess
that's what i would think they probably
determined that i was harassing trans
people by making objectively correct
statements
and not even again making those
statements to them but just in general
in much the same way that i guess that
my math teachers in elementary school
harassed me by telling me that i was
doing long division wrong
you know the truth is harassment if you
don't want to hear it
that seems to be the standard though
rather unevenly applied of course
now fortunately i was let out of uh of
time out the next day and i was
permitted to continue posting
um
you know whatever i want i mean posting
videos of my sled races if i wanted to
but whether i can continue to post
scientifically correct information about
sex and gender is another matter
i will continue to do it
we'll just see how much more they
tolerate before before they ban me
now although my twitter suspension was
obviously a great hardship for me and
i'm still struggling with ptsd from the
experience
i'm aware that it's not exactly
earth-shattering news for everybody else
especially because this kind of thing
happens all the time
the point that has greater implications
for society is not that this or that
individual person gets suspended or
banned
it's that the most powerful social media
platforms on the planet
have forbidden us from stating basic
objective truths
now although we have perhaps grown
accustomed to it by now
it is nonetheless mind-numbingly
deranged that multi-billion dollar
companies have decided that you cannot
say
biological males are men
many of the dystopian novelists of the
20th century were able to correctly
predict various aspects of our society
today but none of them predicted this
none of them prophesied a future a near
future where it's considered harassment
to observe that an individual with a
penis is a man
this goes far beyond the darkest
nightmares of orwell or huxley and it of
course extends beyond social media there
are efforts now to impose these kinds of
rules on the entire country from the
federal level in the form of bills like
the equality act
school districts have adopted these
policies like in loudoun county major
corporations across the spectrum have
imposed them on their employees
and we cannot lose sight of just how
exceedingly psychotic all of this truly
is
now of course i say psychotic in a
colloquial sense
the people imposing these rules are not
actually crazy
some of these people that are imposing
the rules on behalf of are crazy
but the people coming up with the rules
are not crazy
they are acting with intent and with
clear and coherent goals in mind
part of what drives a censorship is that
the left's gender ideology
is a fragile and vulnerable thing and
they know it
it cannot stand up to the slightest
scrutiny
it can only be defended if all of the
opponents are cleared from the playing
field ahead of time it could only stand
up if no wind is allowed to blow
over at the university of pennsylvania
biological male swimmer leah thomas
just won uh this this just few days ago
first place in the 200 and 500 yard
freestyle races in a meet against
females
now he was defeated
in the 100 freestyle
race however by yale's isaac hennig who
is also transgender
so a trans
person beating another trans person in
the female me now the interesting thing
is that hennig is a female who now
identifies as male
which means that in the women's
competition men who call themselves
women are allowed to participate but so
are women who call themselves men
it is total indefensible insanity
though a journalist on nbc this weekend
tried to defend it anyway and let's
listen to that
so let's talk about it now with joe your
caba from nbc out who just published the
speech with the latest about leah joe
i'm glad to have you glad to have you
here talk about what's going on here
right um because leah does have support
from her team from her school from her
league if you will and yet for some of
her detractors that doesn't seem to be
enough
sure yeah so there are a few different
arguments happening here you've got an
argument about fairness there are people
who oppose trans women competing in
women's sports because they say it's
unfair to cisgender women who aren't
trans most of whom don't receive the
athletic athletic advantages of higher
testosterone levels during puberty
though then you have folks who say
there's very little scientific evidence
that shows that those advantages carry
over for trans women after transition so
then you've got this argument about
fairness and human rights on the other
side and trans advocates say that this
question of inclusion is about more than
just sports because you know we're still
seeing these efforts at the state level
to ban trans people from using the
bathrooms of their gender so they say
this debate is really part of a larger
conversation about whether trans people
can participate in certain aspects of
society at all
just one minute there and somehow they
managed to pack like a half dozen lies
into it every word of what you just
heard is false
it's not true that leah thomas has
support from his teammates
they hate the fact that he's there they
by no means are thrilled to have this
big bulky guy intruding in their space
but they'll be punished if they say
anything on the record about it they
have talked off the record but that's
all they can do
as for the claim that there's no
scientific evidence that biological
males have advantages in sports
that would be true if you simply ignore
literally all of the evidence because
every piece of evidence available
confirms over and over and over again
that males have an advantage
i mean every single piece of evidence
there is no evidence on the other side
of this
and yet it's not even our side that
needs to produce evidence
if you wish to contradict thousands of
years of human knowledge and experience
which you're free to do
it's you who must meet the burden of
proof
you must provide evidence that they
don't have an advantage which you have
not and never will because you can't
and it's also not true that people are
trying to stop transgenders from
participating from participating in
society nobody has made any such attempt
or suggested anything like that
i am not aware of any law or any
proposal anywhere at any point
that would prohibit trans people from
using the bathroom that would not be a
sanitary policy for one thing it also
certainly wouldn't be fair the question
is whether trans people should be
required to stick with their biological
sex in these contexts
or if they should get special treatment
so once again everything you heard there
was a lie
because all they can do is lie
which is no surprise
given that they are waging a war on
truth
and that's what this is about
but the lies are so brazen so empty
so glaringly obvious and false
that the truth just cannot be allowed
within its proximity at all
the lies would shrivel and die
they cannot endure the slightest
challenge
that's why they censor
what other choice do they have
tell the truth
i mean well they obviously can't do that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
um all right so we start with this some
sad news troubling news congresswoman
alexander casa cortez announced on
sunday
um
that she has tested positive for covet
19.
it's from the daily wire reporting now
the announcement comes just a week after
the new york representative was caught
vacationing in florida and partying at a
drag club with celebrity billy porter um
while skipping voting in person at the
capitol in washington dc because of the
ongoing emergency pandemic she said
and she also wasn't wearing a mask for
for much of this so
but you know she went to a super
spreader event mask lists at a drag
party and now she has coveted
i guess you know kovit has a crush on
aoc
seriously kovit
back off
why are you so obsessed with aoc covet
it's it's super creepy all right
um
that's all the analysis i have on that
we'll move on to the next thing from cnn
it says the supreme court's conservative
majority on friday appeared ready to
reject one of president biden's most
aggressive attempts so far to combat the
spread of cover 19 a vaccine or testing
requirement aimed at large businesses
but in a separate challenge some
justices ju some justice seemed more
open to a vaccine mandate aimed at
certain health care workers
the court heard arguments for almost
four hours as the number of infections
is soaring and 40 million adults in the
us are still declining to get vaccinated
the three liberal justices on the court
expressed clear approval for the
administration's rules in both areas
so based on the um on the arguments
anyway it seems
likely
that
the uh
mandate will get at least
huge swaths of the mandate will get
will be shut down as well it should be
but you know i i didn't listen to all
the arguments from from the clips that
i've heard and what i've read
the the one fact that
i think was not
doesn't seem to have been focused on
enough
and to me this is this is the decisive
fact right
it's because we can put all the civil
liberty questions aside as important as
they are
and obviously in a supreme court
challenge you have to focus on those
because that's what this is about it's
about the constitution
so it's a constitutional challenge
but you but in reality you could really
put all that aside and just look at the
fact
that the vaccines do not prevent
transmission of the virus which the cdc
and we'll play some clips here in just a
second
but the cdc is finally admitting that
even the cdc is saying that at this
point it doesn't prevent transmission
so
let's let's just say in a fantasy world
that um pfizer and moderna
had come up with a vaccine that does
prevent transmission
you know
even then i would not be in favor of
vaccine mandates imposed by the federal
government because then we go over to
the civil liberty issue
but if there could be any argument if
there could be any argument in favor of
these things
that argument has to hinge
on the vaccine
stopping the spread of of the virus
because then you're saying that this is
a public health necessity and so we have
to put these other liberty issues on
pause or whatever it's a bad argument's
a weak argument
but if the if the vaccine does not
prevent transmission there's no argument
that is you know the other strategy here
and i just i just saw this headline pop
up that um right now the pharmaceutical
industry
they are uh working hard on a a vaccine
specifically for omicron or i'm sorry
i mean mispronounce it omnicorn so
they're working hard on a vaccine for
omnicorn and they hope to have that
ready you know in the next few months
so sort of like an in a similar move i
you know i'm i'm uh organizing an effort
to supply more lifeboats to the titanic
you know that that's that's the great
thing is uh
that's one way maybe where the vaccines
will work is if you
if you if you start vaccinating
everybody against omnicorn after
everyone's gotten it already
and then you know so they'll wait till
everyone gets it and it peters out on
its own and then they give the vaccine
and uh a few weeks later they could say
look no one's getting omnicorn anymore
it worked
so unless you're using a strategy like
that these vaccines are not stopping
transmission
which means that there is no rational
argument for them at all the argument is
gone
because this is not you're not
protecting public health anymore you're
not stopping anyone from getting it
but the real headline for them from the
arguments on friday was the avalanche of
misinformation from the liberal justices
and uh going back to the cdc bret baer
had the cbc director olensky on his show
on sunday
and asked her about some of that uh the
misinformation and we'll start with this
because there was a claim made by
sotomayor that a hundred thousand
children
are hospitalized with covid and um
walenski was asked about that let's
let's listen
we just heard about the u.s supreme
court currently deciding the fate of the
president's vaccine mandates in the
questioning
justice sonia sotomayor made this
statement
we have over a hundred thousand children
which we've never had before in in
serious condition
and uh many on ventilators
now
we can find from friday suggests there
are fewer than 3 500 current pediatric
hospitalizations from covet 19. is that
true
yeah but you know here's what i can tell
you about our pediatric hospitalizations
now first of all the vast majority of
children who are in the hospital are
unvaccinated and for those children who
are not eligible for vaccination we do
know that they are most likely to get
sick with covid if their family members
aren't vaccinated so the most important
thing we can do for those children to
keep them out of the hospital is to
vaccinate them and to vaccinate their
family members around them understood
but the number is not 100 000. it's
roughly 3 500. in hospitals
well you know 100 000
3 500
what's what's the difference uh later on
in the conversation wellencia was asked
whether she feels any responsibility to
fact check the supreme court because
you know that's something that
allegedly the cdc has been doing
wallenski's been doing uh we we know
that that misinformation supposedly is a
big problem and so when we get
misinformation from the nation's highest
court
uh from up from a platform with that
much prestige
is it necessary to fact check it and uh
welleske wasn't so sure about that
from your data ages 15 to 24 for example
the risk of death is at
0.001 percent
um i i guess what i'm getting at in this
opening is that the supreme court is in
the process of dealing with this big
issue about mandates and do you feel a
responsibility as a cdc director to
correct a very big mischaracterization
by one of the supreme court justices
yeah
here's what i'll tell you i'll tell you
that right now 17 you're if you're
unvaccinated you're 17 times more likely
to be in the hospital and 20 times more
likely to die than if you're on than if
you're boosted and so what my
responsibility is is to provide guidance
and recommendations to protect the
american people those recommendations
strongly uh
recommend vaccination for our children
above the age of five and boosting for
everyone above the age of 18 if they're
eligible
well you know we don't we don't need to
worry about misinformation when it's
coming from that side
uh she was also asked at a different
point how many of the deaths because
this is now a subject that we're allowed
to suddenly talk about
um
how many of the deaths
coveted deaths of the 800 plus thousand
how many of them are deaths from covid
as opposed to with covet this was the
the unspeakable
thing for about two years you were not
allowed to talk about it that was going
to be that would be a quick easy ban
from pretty much any social media
platform
if you had uh suggested such a thing
and but now we're allowed to talk about
it she was asked during that same
interview how many of the deaths are
from code as opposed to with cobit and
she said well we gotta i'll i'll look
into that and we'll get that information
over to you know we're still we're still
putting the numbers together yeah she's
still putting the numbers together two
years into it
um
so she didn't want to answer that
question on fox but the next morning on
good morning america this morning
she uh admitted another interesting fact
about the cove of deaths listen
the overwhelming number of deaths over
75 percent occurred in people who had at
least four comorbidities so really these
are people who were unwell to begin with
another two years almost three years
into it
first time we've heard that from her
not the first time we've heard it but
from someone like her so what what
exactly is going on i mean
we finally have
people in the mainstream media
talking about the effects that the
shutdowns the lockdowns are having on
kids and we how we can't keep doing this
uh the the trade-off that that's been
made and how much it's damaged children
they're finally talking about that
they're talking about the difference
between dying from covet and with it
um we're even getting now admissions
about the fact that the vaccines do not
prevent the spread of the virus why is
this happening right now
well a cynical person also just a
logical person might look at the fact
that we are almost exactly a year into
the biden administration
at this point
and cases are surging to record highs
um deaths have gone down
which is another thing that now
the public health authorities and the
media they're also pointing to that
um which they hadn't done in the past
you know in the past it was well we're
just going to focus on cases and uh even
if deaths are lagging behind where you
know
let's worry about the cases
but cases are surging to record highs
a year into the to the biden
administration
and we're coming up now on midterm
elections
and now they're finally admitting some
basic truths about the virus
because they realized that
biden promised to shut down the virus
hasn't happened it's never going to
happen
the people who were stupid enough to
vote for him
based on that promise and promises like
it
they're going to be upset
and they're going to look there's going
to be a price to pay at the polls
so now the media and the democrat party
they have they have several months of
this cleanup effort that they can do
and the cleanup is going to be um
erasing and reversing everything they've
been saying for the last two to three
years
now one other clip i want to play for
you because i thought this was
interesting over on waters world on fox
uh he had an expert on to talk about
something that i hadn't heard until i
saw this this clip
but the the possibility that omicron
omnicorn i keep getting wrong i'm sorry
was uh was also a lab leak so we know
that the original covet strain was most
likely leaked from a lab
um another thing that you weren't
allowed to talk about for two years and
now suddenly you're allowed to talk
about but uh omicron also
was potentially a lab leak let's listen
to that
research suggests and evidence suggests
that they were doing experiments on mice
in a lab in south africa we don't know
which lab do we know which lab
uh we do we have we have some
information
from that there are actually several
laboratories so we don't have that that
final bit of information uh i just soon
not go there on i understand
and they were trying to
do experiments in order to get ahead of
the virus in order to make sure
that a vaccine would help it or doing
research and it escaped because that's
what viruses do it would this have been
gain of function research in a south
african lab
it's effectively is gain of function if
you're trying to teach a virus how to
get around human antibodies it's gaining
the function to get around human
antibodies growing in mice it's gaining
the ability to grow in mice so yeah both
of those do qualify as gain of function
all right
well i guess the good news is this is a
pretty weak strain
uh it's not a mutation as far as we can
tell as far as the research shows and
and it's going to wash through and give
the i guess hopefully the whole country
enough immunity
that this thing kind of decelerates and
we can
turn the page on on covid19 is that your
understanding
absolutely yeah so it grows faster than
delta in the in the nose and the throat
grows much slower in the lungs the
consequence is that you know it's very
transmissible the most transmissible
virus we've ever seen basically the
sneeze heard around the world is enough
to to fill a room with it
but just doesn't go deep in your lungs
to cause pneumonia so it's sort of the
white hat perfect virus if you could if
you had to engineer one
if you had to engineer one which it
sounds like this one was
uh even though
if
omnicorn
kind of works out because it's a weaker
strain taking over for
um the
the deadlier strains
but even so another virus potentially
escaped from a lab
maybe we should just stop doing this
kind of research entirely it's sort of
amazing when you think about all of the
the red tape that governs most of our
lives and especially if you're a
business owner you know you know this
better than anybody else
um all of the
all of the the policies that are put in
place all of the red tape ever every
every aspect of everything that you do
you is has
oversight from like three different
layers of government
to make sure that everything is safe
nobody gets hurt
and yet you've got these
labs across the world
that are just
they're just letting
letting letting viruses escape and next
you know millions of people are dead
and we we barely even talk about it
of course there's no no consequences for
anybody nobody pays any price for that
whatsoever
so you know if you want to open up a if
you're if your 10 year old daughter
wants to open up a lemonade stand uh
outside your your front door
that might get shut down by the
government in fact there's been many
cases of that happening
or you're going to get a the
government's going to shut that one down
because it's not safe you know this is
this is unregulated lemonade that's
being
let loose into the community
who knows what could happen
your daughter might be a psychopath
lacing it with arsenic
so they're going to shut that down right
away if you try to have the unsanctioned
lemonade stand without all of the
licenses and everything that you need
all the permissions
but you want to open up a virus lab
somewhere across the world
that's perfectly fine
several million people die yeah whatever
here's a local news report about a
teacher who went to shall we say extreme
lengths to protect herself
from her son when she thought that he
might have had coveted listen
a local teacher is accused of putting
her son in the trunk of her car while
she got tested for covid according to
the district attorney's office she said
he tested positive and she was trying to
isolate him and now we're learning that
that woman is a teacher at a local
school district our bill barajas is live
now in northwest harris county with the
latest bill
well scifir isd tells us she is a 41
year old sarah beam a cypress falls high
school teacher according to court
records that teacher went to pridgeon
stadium's testing site on monday with
her son in the trunk of her car because
he had tested positive for covet and she
did not want to be exposed so she has
been now charged with endangering a
child
well when i first heard this uh story i
know it does it doesn't surprise me that
it's a teacher i probably could have
told you that
i just
you hear these kinds of stories
and it sends chills down my spine when i
think about the kids who are in who are
in in these households
governed by these coveted psychopaths
imagine i mean this poor kid imagine
what he's had to endure but seriously
imagine what he's had to endure for the
last two to three years
and it always goes back like we've been
talking about you know it goes back to
yeah this is uh
germaphobia and all of those kinds of
things super paranoid people
um and uh
many of them have just been their brains
have been broken by the media the media
by the way you know condemning this
woman but of course it's partly their
fault they're they're partly responsible
for this kind of thing they have
intentionally broken everybody's brains
and then and then this is what happens
as a result
so all of that factors into it but then
also there is this
this
obsessive self-centeredness
from these parents
who are not primarily concerned
with the safety of their own kids
they're just thinking about themselves
and they will inflict any torture on
their children to keep themselves safe
all right let's move on to this from the
daily wire it says on wednesday nights
kevin porter jr of the houston rockets
knocked down a three-pointer with .4
seconds left in the game to beat the
washington wizards 114 to 111. the
game-winning shot should have been the
story but it was the reaction by a
member of the wizard broadcast team that
stole the show
on the replay of the shot wizards
broadcaster glenn consor made a comment
that immediately set social media on
fire consort said
what a well-designed play you got to
give credit kevin porter jr like his dad
pulled that trigger right at the right
time
that's what he said in the
in the broadcast
and you know pulling the trigger is kind
of a common
uh phrase that you hear from from sports
broadcasters common metaphor
but it says the problem with the
reference to porter jr's father is that
brian kevin porter senior spent more
than four years in prison for the 1993
shooting death of a 14 year old girl and
then was shot and killed in 2004.
according to usa today porter junior's
father brian kevin porter sooner senior
pleaded guilty to first degree
manslaughter in a shooting death of a 14
year old girl in 1993 was sentenced to
four and a half years in prison porter
senior then died in 2004 after being
shot in a south seattle bar
um
the rocket star was four years old when
his father was killed
now
of course so he makes this comment
ends up on social media
and uh because i mean
you have to keep in mind that of
everyone watching the wizards game and
they heard that comment
99.999 percent if not all of them
they wouldn't have any idea about the
the criminal history of kevin porter
jr's father they would have heard that
comment and they would have thought
nothing of it
they would have assumed that um that
this basketball player has a father who
played in the nba at one point and
that's what they would have assumed
but you know one person on social media
does the google search makes the
connection
um puts it out there and uh next thing
you know this guy is getting blasted by
everyone he's getting going calling for
him to be fired and everything else
lebron james jumps on the dog pile uh
lebron james tweeted oh we thought this
was cool huh nah we ain't going for this
sorry but this ain't gonna fly how
insensitive can you be to say something
like this
beat it man i pray for you but there's
no place in our beautiful game for you
yeah i pray for you i want your life to
be ruined and i'm going to use my
immense platform to do it
um but um but i'm praying for you as i
ruin your life
immediately follow the uh following the
call many wondered whether concert was
referring to former nba player kevin
porter mistakenly believing him to be
porter jr's father
and then it turns out that the uh
broadcaster that's exactly what happened
he put out a statement apologizing
where uh he apologizes and said is he
sincerely sorry for it but then he says
i mistakenly thought kevin was the son
of former washington player kevin porter
and was unaware that the words i choose
chose to describe the game-winning shot
would be in any way hurtful or
insensitive i've reached out to kevin to
personally apologize and hope to be able
to talk with him soon so
again most people will hear this not
think anything of it then when you look
into it and you see that okay well this
guy's name is kevin porter he's playing
for washington
uh years back there was another guy
named kevin porter who played for
washington
this broadcaster was aware of that and
assumed that there was a family relation
and that's what he was talking about
so this was just a mistake an accident
it happens
and yet even after he explained this
which is a perfectly logical
explanation and that makes a lot more
sense i mean you know we we can't know
what was going on in this guy's head and
what his motivations were
but either
he mistakenly thought that the old kevin
porter was the father of this kevin
porter and that's the point he was then
that's the reference
or
he was making a joke about an nba star's
father killing someone
because he wanted to destroy his own
career
you know either this was a simple
mistake or this broadcaster committed an
act of random career suicide for no
apparent reason
which explanation makes the most sense
well obviously the simple mistake makes
the most sense
and yet even after he explained and
provide a very reasonable explanation
for the comment
still people want him fired anyway
including lebron james
who after his most recent game he was
talking to the media and he's still
offended by this still very upset and he
still wants this guy punished for it
let's listen
uh i stand by my tweet and i stand by
everything i said so okay let's just say
let's just say he thought that was the
case
so
we get we get
we get uh scouting reports on players
and i know you guys from the media you
all get memos and stuff from players and
stuff before the game right
y'all get like packets and stuff when
y'all come to the game and what's going
on in the game's way
and i believe that
i'm not a play-by-play person analyst
but i believe that they do they do
dillages as well and they get their
reports on teams that they're about to
play
as long as their own team right
so
i i was actually watching the game live
last night when i heard it um and i
waited i didn't do it right away as you
seen from my tweet i was watching the
game
so
if that's the case if if if i am a a
play-by-play announcer right
and
i'm
covering a team in my local
my local team in his case he's covering
the wizards so he remembers the kevin
porter who used to play for the bullets
correct
the first
thing i would have done
i would have said oh kevin porter jr is
coming into town
let me see if that's his son okay all
right
thanks lebron shut up shut up shut up
uh so
yeah well so really this guy the brother
broadcaster the announcer he still
deserves to be fired um
consort deserves to be fired because
uh as lebron points out you know it was
his job to research the family tree
of every single player
um that uh that is involved in a game
that he's calling the fact that he
didn't do that
means that sorry sorry bud your life's
over yeah you should have known better
before you call a game you got to look
up the rosters and every single person
any of the starters but also the bench
players because they might they might
take the court and if you think that you
might be referring them you got to look
up their entire family tree
going back at least 100 years
and if you didn't do that
well sorry
your your life is over
that's what lebron is saying you see
here again how canceled culture of
course has absolutely nothing to do with
holding people accountable
um it's also not even really like an
overreaction
to people who do or say bad things
because there's a complete disconnect
here
this was
intention does not matter motivation
doesn't matter
it's especially if you're not in a
victim class
so consor
who i believe is a white guy
as a as a member of a non-victim class
when he says something
he does not get to decide the intentions
of his own words he doesn't get to
determine why he said something or what
he meant
his own intentions and motivations are
not up to him
they're up to members of the victim
class like lebron james who's certainly
a victim
he's worth like a billion dollars he's
beloved and world famous and everything
but he's a victim
he's certainly more of a victim than
just some local broadcaster for the
wizards
apparently
and so lebron as a member of victim
class he gets to decide
what your motives and intentions were
and that's what this is about all right
one other thing before we get to the
comment section
i thought this was just great uh check
out this tweet from a guy named john
reese
so he tweeted this he says
even after a 12-hour night shift at the
hospital last night my wife still has
the energy to shovel the driveway
god bless her and all our front liners
time to make her some breakfast
and then there's a picture that he took
of his of his wife down there after a
12-hour shift
uh shoveling the driveway
john still has his pajamas on you know
he's sipping a cup of coffee looking out
there so proud of his wife
but this is really outrageous i gotta
say i saw this tweet and i was pretty
upset
i mean what is this guy thinking
he's making her breakfast
she's perfectly capable obviously
i mean honestly
you're telling me she came home
and it's what is it uh eight o'clock in
the morning john your wife comes home
for the 12 hour shift and then
immediately went out to shovel the
driveway and didn't make you breakfast
does she want you to starve to death
it's eight o'clock in the morning should
i have breakfast breakfast already how
selfish is this woman
i just hope she finished the laundry
before she uh went to bed after that
because those clothes won't fold
themselves
ladies
now let's get to the comment section
[Music]
uh il berto says next next matt needs to
film the podcast in a parking lot where
he can yell at people not returning
their carts in between thoughts
that's not a bad idea but there actually
is already um
in a there's it's not really a show but
there's an account at least on twitter
called carton arcs
and i think they're on youtube as well
carton arcs and this is this is what
they this is what they do this is the
service that they provide they patrol
parking lots
and when they find someone not returning
cart they go and yell at that person and
shame them publicly
but needless to say they're it's it's
heroic and uh so that that service is
already being provided
but otherwise maybe i would think about
doing that war fan says i honestly don't
care about january 6 where politicians
felt unsafe for a few hours
compared to my city of atlanta being
destroyed by thousands of rioters it was
like something out of a movie with
police cars torched and flipped over and
businesses completely destroyed
not big stores either local shops that
still have not reopened and probably
never will
yeah this is
this is the inversion where we're
supposed to feel uh
great sympathy
for politicians who had an unpleasant
afternoon
but nothing for average citizens who
watched their neighborhoods burned to
the ground
david says
i love how the other daily wire hosts
get a quality upgrade and matt says
no thanks i'll go back to my car i hope
you enjoyed that though um that was our
one trip down memory lane
but that's that era is officially over
so i'm not doing that again
i got by by the end of the second show
of doing that when it's 18 degrees
outside
and i'm just freezing my ass off out
there
doing my podcast in my card i'm thinking
you know
what am i what am i doing with my life
right now what was the point of this
exactly
so i hope it was worth it
never happening again i can tell you
um alex says is anybody in the daily
wire going to talk about the ted cruz
situation or are we also going to play
the liberal media role and ignore when
convenient is tucker the only journalist
holding him accountable
um
i'm not avoiding talking about it
um
it's also
sometimes when there's an issue that's
that has already been discussed ad
nauseam i'm not sure if i have much
worthwhile to add to the conversation
but yeah ted cruz uh in congress last
week i'm sure you heard and then he went
on tucker the next day to talk about it
but he referred to
january 6 as a terrorist attack
any sense he went on he went on tucker's
show to talk about it which i think was
you know in hindsight pretty clearly a
mistake to do that
but he has since backed away from that
and said that he was being sloppy in his
wording um yeah i i totally disagree
that it was a terrorist attack i don't
think that's it was it was a riot that's
what it was
um
it also wasn't simply a protest so we
can't be like the leftists in in doing
that well we're going to look at a riot
and say oh it's just a protest so it's
clearly a right i mean there there were
plenty of people there who did not take
part in the riot
and it began as not a riot but it did
devolve into that and there's no no
doubt about it so that's what it was
that's that's everything that it was it
was a right
and as we have talked about at great
length it was um not nearly as violent
deadly dangerous
harmful
as the blm rights but that's what it was
and that's what we should call it was
not a terrorist attack it was not an
insurrection
so i disagree with ted cruz there i
think he was wrong
he shouldn't have said that he's backed
away from it which is good
um you know that i'm not afraid to to
hold politicians on our side and the
republic if we can even say the
republican party is our side i'm not
afraid to hold them accountable to
criticize them
in fact i not only am i not afraid to do
it i quite enjoy it any opportunity to
criticize a politician i'll uh
i will take advantage of
but i also think
you know
there are very few
republicans
that are any good at all
very few that we can trust very few that
we rely on very few solid conservatives
in the senate or in the house
or on the on the political scene at all
we only have a few
ted cruz is one of the few
and so we have to ask ourselves
he makes one mistake he says one thing
that's wrong are we just going to toss
them overboard completely and say we're
done with you forever because of that
it seems like there are plenty of people
on the right who are taking that
approach i just don't
to me that seems kind of penny wise and
pound foolish
i'm not sure i agree with that as a
long-term strategy
because he said this one thing that i
certainly disagree with and was wrong
does that mean that he'll he never he
has nothing else to offer us
we should want to get rid of him and put
someone else in there
come re-election i i don't see it that
way
all right
um
jess says i told my husband i inducted
our daughter into the sbg and he asked
what that was and i told him the first
rule of the spg
he now thinks i'm on drugs
well
then that means that you are a true
member of the sweet baby gang you
handled that
very well i applaud you for that
um
and let's see what else
aaron says matt you have scarred me in
the middle of your show you did a
segment on a woman who sells her farts i
was so shocked and disgusted that
there'd actually be a market for that
kind of thing as i recovered from the
shock i then focused my attention
expecting to hear your commentary and
most importantly your reasoning for why
you'd fill a segment slot with that you
then made some fart jokes and moved on
i couldn't believe you would implant
such a thing in my brain for the sake of
a few subpar dad jokes thanks for that
i'm now thoroughly scarred
really well i gotta say i don't know if
you're a true member of the sweet baby
game you might be banned from the show
for this
you didn't you didn't see that coming
from a mile away you didn't uh shall we
say sniff that one out
what else am i gonna do with a story
like that of course
all i can do is just make fart puns
you're banned from the show
well when everybody else is kneeling
some men have the courage to stand alone
one of those men is nba star jonathan
isaac who despite facing heavy criticism
from the media for his views on social
issues and vaccines over the past few
years still stood strong which is why
i'm extremely excited to announce that
he's dedicated to decided rather to
write a book with a daily wire called
why i stand jonathan's book will be
about the rise of his basketball career
his journey into faith and his strength
to stand alone in the face of immense
pressure check out the teaser the
orlando magic's 23 year old starting
forward is deeply religious and proudly
unvaccinated on friday isaac got
attention for choosing not to kneel in
unison with his teammates or to wear a
black lives matter shirt my name is
jonathan isaac i play for the orlando
magic
and i'm writing a book with the daily
wire
[Music]
courage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes
[Music]
jonathan's book will be one of the first
under the daily wires new publishing arm
not the very first that was johnny the
walrus uh but one of the first under our
publishing arm dw books and we couldn't
be happier to have him on board the book
is available for pre-order now at amazon
so reserve your copy today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel alleged covet expert
dr bob wachter
i first became aware of bob and his
plight from a san francisco chronicle
article that someone shared on twitter
it said the headline was medicine meets
emotion coveted expert shares what
happened when his son tested positive
the article tells us the retweets likes
and comments lit up for hours saturday
after a well-known san francisco covet
expert posted an extraordinary story on
twitter what followed in 25 tweets
revealed a kind of wrestling match
within wachter an internal contest
between the data savvy physician who
knew that a young triple vaccinated
person would probably weather kova just
fine and the loving father who felt the
pandemic's pain up close perhaps for the
first time
wow it sounds pretty harrowing
now at this point
let's just jump over to the threat
itself it is as mentioned 25 tweets long
i've i have literally written books
shorter than that
johnny the walrus available
johnnywolves.com by twitter standards 25
tweets is like war and peace this is
what it would have been like if twitter
existed in the 19th century and russian
novelists were on the platform but let's
see if the story dr bob tells is worth
the page as it takes to tell it he
begins
i've been tweeting about covet for
nearly two years but this week it became
personal when my 28 year old younger son
got it with his permission i'll describe
his experience and how i approach the
situation given the realities of life
and the rapidly changing evidence my son
who lives in san francisco is generally
healthy but overweight placing him in a
moderately high-risk group he's been
quite careful since march 2020 has
received three modernists he used to
wear a two-ply cloth mask since ami he's
switching to a kn 995 with my
encouragement
let's pause there for a second so his
son had three shots and wears an n95
mask and he still got covet
there would seem to be a lesson there
but as usual this covet expert isn't
perceptive or honest enough to learn it
instead he rambles on and on about his
son's diagnosis throwing in dramatic
details such as how he called his son a
day after he first started feeling sick
didn't receive an answer so he went to
his apartment let himself in with the
key that he apparently has and found him
asleep
now already we get the impression that
he treats his 28 year old son like it's
his eight-year-old son
then he tells us that he gave his son a
coveted test
quote
the 15-minute wait
and then
dot dot dot
the pink line
he was positive
like millions of other young people my
son had coveted
i felt a strange guilt
not entirely rational but real for not
having protected him
protected him dude he's 28
what might you have done to stop your 28
year old from getting a virus that
everyone in the world is getting
i mean i suppose you could have kept
them contained in a large glass box in
your home like some kind of gerbil
maybe give them a giant wheel to run on
for recreation he is overweight after
all but short of that there's literally
nothing you could have done or should
have attempted to do
your son is one in a line of millions
who did everything right quote unquote
in order to escape the fate of everyone
else only to share in it anyway
again that should be the lesson
but you have to be both smart and humble
enough to see it and dr bob is neither
of those things apparently but maybe i'm
giving the good doctor a hard time
unfairly i mean we haven't found out if
his kid fared how his kid fared with the
illness yet maybe he was severely or
even deathly sick which would explain
why dr bob is being so frantic and
dramatic about the whole thing reading
on
he called in sick to work
set himself up for at least five days of
strict isolation and i set out to figure
out his prognosis and if treatment was
merited
wait pause again why are you doing all
of this for your grown-ass son
can he call the doctor himself
i got coveted a few weeks ago my dad
didn't come busting into my house early
in the morning to make sure i was still
alive
nor did he call the doctor for me
i guess he respects me as a man and
knows i can do it myself or or he hates
me you know those are the two options
maybe both
continuing after several more tweets
talking about all the treatment options
and blah blah he tells us quote
i called his doctor because of course
he's he's calling his son's doctor for
him
i wonder if his doc his son still goes
to a pediatrician i'm guessing he does i
called his doctor who noted that the
pills have benefited the covet pills the
the i think it's the pfizer coconuts
have benefit when used before day five
i'd err on not treating he said wisely
but might consider if things worse in
the next couple of days it's now day
four
pulse oxometer is fine heart rate has
slowed he's a bit less fluid but his
throat still hurts like hell when five
days are up we'll do another rapid if i
can find one if negative he'll leave
isolation and wear a kn-95
okay that answers that question his son
had flu symptoms for a few days he was
never seriously ill and now he's mostly
fine but he has a sore throat
the end
well not the end of the thread he goes
on for like five more paragraphs but
that's the whole story so to summarize
his 28 year old son had a cold
now he's fine
somehow his dad found a way to turn it
into like the epic of gilgamesh
perhaps i'm jealous of his creativity my
whole family got covered including all
my kids and i couldn't get more than
about 90 seconds of content out of it on
this show
and i call myself a content creator i'm
a disgrace to my profession i should
also tell you by the way that when my
kids got covered i didn't have any like
internal crisis i did i didn't feel
guilty i didn't um i didn't freak out
you know at all
i said well i got covered it was to
happen eventually
or maybe you know dr bob is the one who
should feel embarrassed though he's not
alone social media is full of these
kinds of lengthy confessionals whenever
somebody in the public eye gets coveted
or their family gets it
they feel the need to narrate the whole
experience at length in exorbitant
detail even if nothing significant ever
actually happened
so we see here that narcissism is partly
what drives the coveted panic
first there's the narcissism of actually
believing that you and your loved ones
somehow will never contract this virus
that billions have already contracted
these people feel shocked when coveted
finally knocks on their door because
they had assumed that kovid would pass
over them like the angel of death
if they performed the necessary rituals
and smeared the right kind of blood on
their doors
everybody else can get it they think but
but i should not get it
and therefore when i do get it it's a
big deal
yes a billion people already had this
experience but none of those people are
me
my experience is profound
because it's my experience
these are the kinds of people who go to
a famous tourist spot that 100 million
people have already visited before them
and take a thousand pictures and then
force you to look at them
hey look at these pictures i took of the
grand canyon why
you think i've never seen a picture of
the grand canyon
your grand canyon trip may be
significant to you but to the rest of us
there's nothing significant about the
fact that you visited one of the most
famous tourist destinations in the world
so
kind of a similar situation here but
there's something else going on as well
most of us live lives of previously
unimaginable comfort and ease and luxury
we simply don't have very many truly
harrowing experiences most of us don't
we don't suffer very much because every
aspect of modern life is obsessively
focused on preventing suffering for
better or worse but we've discovered
that that actually
humans need to suffer a little bit it's
hard to see the purpose in life if
everything goes your way all the time
it's hard to know where to go if every
obstacle you encounter just magically
moves out of the way and clears the path
for you
sometimes you need to run into something
solid something that will push back a
little bit
a life of relentless comfort gets sort
of boring after a while
it's exhausting in its own way really
maybe not exhausting physically but
spiritually intellectually
all of this to say that people afflicted
by this much comfort
tend sometimes to latch on to the little
bits of suffering they do experience
they cling to those experiences
they walk over flat and easy terrain for
years on end and then encounter one
little speed bump and to them it's as if
they climbed everest and they got to
tell everybody about it
i think that's at least part of the
story here
part of why some people are turning
their cold symptoms into an epic saga
of course many people really have
suffered immensely from covet many
people have actually died but most have
not
most had experiences much like dr bob
and his son
and we in that category should simply be
grateful
yet more suffering we've been spared
isn't that good enough
apparently not
and that's why dr bob is today along
with his son i'm afraid to say
he's a collateral damage
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
a new study shows vaccines can in fact
change women's menstrual cycles justice
sonia sotomayor spreads coveted
misinformation during oral arguments
over the vaccine mandates and yale's
transgender swimmer beat penn's
transgender swimmer during a women's
swimming competition check it out in the
michael knowles show